what happened man how did we get so far  off track what are you talking about we  both have good things going on right now  hey did I see you in a commercial you  did yeah I have I have I have general  herpes what's up you don't jump out on  brothers man you don't like that so  we're going to party tonight cops are  ghosts here choice I don't want to be a  ghost let's be cops people actually  think you can come hahaha what's his  place right oh that was awesome oh oh I  don't have here officers this is is this  for real d where are we planning on  taking this  get this thing you made it is super  illegal right this no huh Wow we could  go to jail for years for this all units  domestic disturbance in progress yes no  yes no no three female early 20s  possibly intoxicated that's how it's  sweet  me  drinks damn in our circle right stand up  sup man  Wow my bad open up oh yeah thank you we  are here it's my sorority sisters  that would you get this one